Ce bâtiment devait accueillir
2500 chevaux de pure race, très nerveux,
qui descendaient de vols long courrier
et souffraient du décalage horaire, donc pas au meilleur de leur forme.
Le problème que l'ingénieur a rencontré
fut la quantité de déchets qui allait devoir sortir du bâtiment.
C'est quelque chose que l'on apprend pas en école d'ingénieurs -- (Rires) --
et c'est une chose sur laquelle on n'aimerait pas se tromper.
Il aurait pu perdre des mois à parler à des vétos, à faire des recherches,
à revoir les feuilles de calculs.
Au lieu de ça, il a demandé de l'aide
à la personne qui avait conçu le Club de Jockey de New York.
Le problème a été résolu en moins d'une journée.
Arup pense que la culture de la collaboration
est au centre de leur succès.
La collaboration, ça fait anémique,
mais c'est vraiment le cœur des équipes performantes,
et elle surpasse très souvent l'intelligence individuelle.
Collaborer, ça veut dire que je ne suis pas obligée de tout savoir,
je dois simplement être avec des gens qui savent demander et donner de l'aide.
Chez SAP, ils disent qu'on peut répondre à n'importe quelle question en 17 minutes.
Mais aucune compagnie high-tech où j'ai travaillé
ne pense que c'est une affaire de technologie.
Ce qui améliore la collaboration, c'est que les gens se connaissent.
Ça paraît si logique que l'on pense que ça arrive naturellement,
mais ce n'est pas le cas.
Quand je dirigeais ma première entreprise, qui vendait des logiciels,
j'ai réalisé qu'on s'enlisait.
Il y avait beaucoup de tensions mais pas grand chose d'autre,
et j'ai compris que ces gens brillants et créatifs que j'avais engagés
ne se connaissaient pas.
Ils étaient tellement concentrés sur leur travail individuel,
qu'ils ne savaient même pas qui était la personne à coté d'eux,
et c'est en insistant pour qu'on arrête de travailler
et qu'on apprenne à se connaître,
qu'on a commencé à avancer.
C'était il y a 20 ans, aujourd'hui je vois des firmes
qui ont interdit les tasses de café sur les bureaux
pour pousser les gens à aller à la machine à café
et à se parler.
Les Suédois ont même un mot spécial pour ça.
Ils l'appellent « Fika », ce qui est plus qu'une pause café.
C'est une restauration collective.
Chez Idexx, une société dans le Maine,
ils ont des potagers afin que les gens
venant de départements différents
puissent travailler ensemble et en apprendre plus sur l'entreprise.
Sont-ils devenus fous ?
Au contraire, ils ont compris que quand les choses deviennent difficiles,
parce qu'elles le deviennent toujours,
il faut offrir des idées nouvelles qui importent vraiment.
Les gens ont besoin de soutien amical,
et ils ont besoin de savoir à qui ils peuvent demander de l'aide.
Les sociétés n'ont pas d'idées, ce sont les gens qui en ont.
Et ce qui motive les gens,
ce sont les liens, la loyauté, la confiance qu'ils développent entre eux.
L'important, c'est le mortier,
pas simplement les briques.
En assemblant tout cela,
vous obtenez ce qu'on appelle le capital social.
C'est la confiance créée par les liens et l'interdépendance.
Le terme a été choisi par des sociologues qui ont étudié des communautés
particulièrement résistantes en période de stress.
Le capital social est ce qui fait avancer les entreprises
et qui les rend plus fortes.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire en pratique ?
Ça veut dire que le temps est important,
parce que le capital social prend de l'importance avec le temps.
Les équipes travaillant ensemble longtemps s'améliorent, parce qu'il faut du temps
pour avoir cette confiance qui permet la franchise et l'ouverture.
Et c'est le temps qui crée cette valeur.
Quand Alex Pentland a suggéré à une entreprise
de synchroniser les pauses café
pour que les gens aient le temps de se parler,
les bénéfices ont augmenté de 15 millions de dollars,
et la satisfaction des employés de 10%.
Pas mal comme retour sur le capital social,
qui croît même quand on l'utilise.
Mais, ce n'est pas du copinage ni de la fainéantise,
car les gens qui travaillent comme ça sont souvent abrupts,
impatients et déterminés à penser pour eux-mêmes,
et c'est comme ça qu'ils contribuent.
Les conflits sont fréquents parce qu'on peut être francs.
Et c'est comme ça que les bonnes idées deviennent des idées géniales,
parce qu'aucune idée ne naît complètement formée.
Elle arrive un peu comme un enfant,
brouillon et désordonnée mais pleine de possibilités.
Ce n'est qu'avec de nombreuses contributions, la confiance et les défis
qu'elle réalise son plein potentiel.
Et c'est ce qu'offre le capital social.
On n'a pas vraiment l'habitude de parler de cela,
du talent et de la créativité, de cette manière.
On a l'habitude de parler des stars.
Je me suis donc demandé si en travaillant comme cela,
on allait détruire toutes les stars.
J'ai assisté aux auditions
de la Royal Academy of Dramatic Art à Londres.
Et j'ai été surprise par ce que j'ai vu :
les professeurs ne cherchaient pas de stars.
Ils cherchaient l’interaction entre les étudiants
parce que c'est là que le théâtre prend vie.
Quand j'ai parlé à des producteurs de musique,
ils m'ont dit : « Oh oui, nous avons beaucoup de superstars,
mais elles ne durent jamais longtemps.
Ce sont les bons collaborateurs qui ont de longues carrières,
parce que c'est en faisant sortir le meilleur des autres qu'ils trouvent
le meilleur d'eux-mêmes. »
Et en visitant des entreprises renommées
pour leur inventivité et leur créativité,
je n'ai vu aucune superstar,
parce que tout le monde y est important.
Et en regardant ma propre carrière,
et tous les gens merveilleux avec qui j'ai eu la chance de travailler,
j'ai compris à quel point on pouvait s'offrir bien plus les uns aux autres
si on essayait simplement d'arrêter de devenir des Super-Poules.
(Rires) (Applaudissements)
Dès que l'on comprend vraiment comment le travail social fonctionne,
beaucoup de choses doivent changer.
Diriger en faisant des concours de talents ne fait souvent que monter
les employés les uns contre les autres.
La rivalité doit laisser place au capital social.
On a longtemps essayé de motiver les gens avec l'argent,
alors que beaucoup de recherches montrent
que l'argent détruit la connectivité sociale.
Il faut laisser les gens se motiver les uns les autres.
On a aussi longtemps pensé qu'un leader était un héros qui, seul,
allait pouvoir résoudre des problèmes difficiles.
Nous devons redéfinir le « leadership »
comme une activité créant les conditions nécessaires
pour que tout le monde puisse oser réfléchir ensemble.
On sait que ça fonctionne.
Quand le Protocole de Montréal a demandé l'élimination progressive des CFC,
les chlorofluorocarbures impliqués dans le trou de la couche d'ozone,
les risques étaient énormes.
Les CFC étaient partout,
et personne ne savait si l'on trouverait un substitut.
Mais une équipe a relevé le défi en adoptant 3 principes clés.
Le premier : le chef de l'ingénierie, Frank Maslen, a annoncé
qu'il n'y aurait pas de stars dans cette équipe.
On a besoin de tout le monde.
Et tout le monde a une vision valide.
Deuxièmement, on travaille suivant une norme :
la meilleure possible.
Et troisièmement, il a dit à son patron, Geoff Tudhope,
qu'il devrait se tenir à l'écart du projet
parce qu'il savait que le pouvoir peut être perturbateur.
Ça ne veut pas dire que Tudhope n'a rien fait.
Il leur a donné le champ libre,
et les a écoutés afin de s'assurer qu'ils respecteraient leurs principes.
Et ça a fonctionné. Ils ont devancé toutes les autres entreprises
en étant les premiers à résoudre ce problème.
Et à ce jour, le Protocole de Montréal
est l'accord environnemental international le plus performant
jamais mis en œuvre.
Il y avait beaucoup d'intérêts en jeu,
et il y a toujours beaucoup d'intérêts en jeu aujourd'hui,
et nous ne résoudrons aucun problème si on s'attend à ce qu'ils soient résolus
par quelques super-hommes ou super-femmes.
On a besoin de tout le monde,
et c'est seulement quand nous comprendrons que tout le monde a de la valeur
que nous libérerons l'énergie et l'imagination dont nous avons besoin
pour créer un monde meilleur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)